yeah it's just interesting to me because
kanye could have anyone he's a
billionaire like why is he picking a
girl that's for the streets
she's made so much money though so
either way she's actually an independent
woman regardless of what she's that's
why the wife of christians
yeah but then again
that kind of stuff is a bit of a wild
yeah but i mean
do you men do you guys care about a
girl's money
no
well not this point but it's nice if you
have money in it yeah
don't be flashing in my face and saying
i don't need you i don't do this i don't
i can do like is is a woman's ceo like
hot to you
yeah yeah
really
yeah independent really
because
i've always heard from guys that they
don't care about a girl's money so it's
interesting that you guys have the
opposite point of view it just depends
on the situation
so for example like
if i'm older and i'm trying to get my
stuff together
and
she hasn't like for example isn't hasn't
been really ambitious
then why would i like go for her because
it's not really in like i'm not going to
elevate myself to a different point in
life
with her but she's not really she
doesn't have money she's not like
ambitious
yes
so what do you think would you date a
guy
that had a sex tape
um
[Music]
would i
[Music]
i mean
if it's not something he's trying to do
again
like on a regular then yeah i think i
would really yeah oh my god though it
really it really does depend is it
leaked
is it something you're doing like every
year
it needs to have content is that what
they don't it's i don't know difficulty
i mean
even nowadays like people are just
recording themselves like it's normal
like that's what i'm saying it's like
it's not if it goes because
like guys are just being like yeah okay
i mean
yeah but like you don't think it's kind
of on the girl to vet the guys she
sleeps with and does that with like
doesn't that kind of say something about
her decision making abilities
i mean it depends on the situation again
because if it's like a past thing and
it's not gonna be
every week or he's going out to do that
or i'm seeing it somewhere else or my
friend's sending it to me then yeah yeah
it's a bit different but if he made
money and income because of right how
kim kaden then
i don't know
okay so now the other question do you
guys think that someone's past
matters to an extent yes
yes yes
obviously it does the reason i say it
does is because
you can enjoy your young ages but don't
destroy it yeah like yeah you have fun
and do whatever like
but if you just go and be loose and just
do everything like it's gonna be hard to
get like
um like but in this day names there's
some girls that have bc's that are older
than their age so it's like by the time
they get into that stage where they want
to like settle down because you've been
around it's like no one's going to take
you seriously yeah maybe one guy will
it'll be very hard to get maybe one
ah there's always hope for everyone in
it but you know like maybe one guy like
well but it's like even if now like you
marry that girl imagine walking down the
road oh yeah like she slopped me off in
the block oh yeah she did
that's something
no but that's something you're gonna
have to live with like for the rest of
your life you get it yeah and
like even if you marry her yeah it's
like cool you have to go through all
this time to marry the girl it took me
what two weeks just to get slops you get
it so it's like
well it's kind of like she gave
something
to that guy for free and she's making
you like pay for it yeah yeah
i'm trying to see
if you've got to pick the right person
for you man
whatever you're ready to deal with
yeah i mean if tj backs meet then they
can be together in it yeah because they
both know what they're on that's crazy
yeah you know i would say though i would
say you like what you like so
if there's a girl that you really like
but a past is crazy
that's not really going to matter too
tough because
you liking her factors more than what
she's done with other people before i
think it depends on like what happens
between when you've started speaking to
her i mean yeah and then moving onwards
if it's still wild then
you'll afraid jesus christ sorry guys
do you guys do you guys ask girls that
you're saying like about what they've
done before or do you just you're like
see no either evil hear no evil like i
don't want to know really i think i
think when you're when you're going to
go
someone knows something do you i mean so
you don't really even have to ask
directly
you can kind of get
a sense of who someone is
just about the way they speak and where
they talk and the way their friends
speak about them and stuff like that
yeah they don't really have to choose
them directly to kind of gauge what's
going on more time they can lie as well
yeah they can actually live maybe would
you know if they're lying
you never know exactly if i tell you
three like you can't argue with me like
a lot of girls know every single person
a lot of girls would say that pc is one
it's really 20.
because they know that because they
don't know but that's actually some
girls some girls would like saying that
their bc is one and if you're oh that's
calm you get to know her and then
because like they know that the type of
guy you are you're not going to deal
with a girl that's like out there so
they're going to have to lie to you but
you that's something you never know
sort of
yeah you should be open from the start
but i guess you can't avoid in certain
situations
but okay so
bc is one thing right
like like a girl what's what she's done
but i think it takes it to another level
when it's on the internet like i have
brothers i would never tell them to deal
with a girl that has any sort of only
fans any sort of sex tape on the
internet like ever
because like your kids are going to see
that one day
and like that's what you're seeing now
with kim kardashian like look at the
like she has to have that conversation
with all four of her kids like can you
imagine having a mom with an oaf like an
only fans
[Music]
[Music]
if
no but if we're talking about like kim k
of course like
her sex tape is going to be out there
because she's really up there but if
we're talking about like a normal person
i think it's going to go away you're not
going to like find a video like of
someone that you don't really know about
mm-hmm i think things definitely like
brush over like think think about coming
along i think about school that time
stuff gets sent around that's like now
do you even remember that no look look
at ash cash bro now
because of what she's done exactly but
like not everyone's going to be popping
like that's right
like that i mean right
now if she's if she's
[Music]
i think there's exceptions to every rule
right but it's still like in general
like i just don't know why as a guy
you'd want to deal with that do you
think that guys put up with like bad
behavior because a chick is like really
good looking some people do yeah i think
it's more easier to look over yeah you
know like let's say like you bagged
let's see
let's see you've had one lengthening now
and it's like the girl is toxic but
because she's lingering you know like if
you have her by her side of my like yeah
i rate your thing so when you go behind
closed doors she might be so toxic like
bro like no one's meant to be going
through that but because she's laying
like she that's what you're like you're
putting up with it because you just want
to keep her there you get it
so yeah
i think a lot of guys care about like
other like guys validating them that's
why they put up with it
and that's how we'll stand from but even
now like girls with bad behavior like
all that toxic [ __ ] like it's normalized
now so
a lot of guys tend to look for that now
it's just crazy yeah some guys like it
man
i have been saying that every show that
i think there's a type of guy that likes
girls that are a little bit mean to them
yeah they're all mean and keep them keen
like no but i don't
like
next next question no like no it will i
just like will smith okay take will
smith no no let's just use him as an
example look at this you you cannot you
can
you can't you cannot tell me that will
smith did not have the option to pick a
girl that was nice to him when he was on
the fresh prince of freaking bel-air
he could have had his pick of what like
lined up
and he picked the one girl
that like is borderline and like abusive
art to him mentally she was in love with
tupac yeah she was in love with someone
else well you're shown like at the
beginning because like what you're shown
like what someone decides to show you
could be completely different than what
they really are do i mean it's like
years down the line it could be tomorrow
but it could be years down she was like
crying on their wedding day what do you
mean
so look how long they would have been
for and obviously there's signs and
stuff but like yeah if you like it you
like it
yeah
now will smith went up on the stage and
actually smacked some of her and she
said that she still did all that all the
madness like that's crazy i could never
have a goal that like i'd do all that
for my man just listen no yes mama made
a joke about your your your head
no no no no no no i'm not trying to
violate no mama made a joke about your
head
no no but no but keep it cool that's one
thing another guy went into your wife
you could even tuck him down to do
nothing like i can't let your waist man
no no viola i'll be so real will smith i
love fresh fruits available like that's
my guy but after i saw that and i saw
everything
there's levels to that you're not gonna
go for the guy bro what are you gonna go
for the guy first her bro but that's
what i'm saying if you're not gonna go
for the guy that went into your wife
don't go for no one that chats about
your wife bro yeah i think there's
levels in it
you sat right there
he was set right there
with your wife bro and someone said you
know it's a little bit more than just
that yeah
but bro but there's a bit more in the
marriage you still let bro you bro your
wife told you in your face on flipping
the whole world knew it bro
you bro i i trucked another guy because
what i needed some sort of security yeah
but whether he made the house he bought
a house for her bro whether you move one
past that is like that's different what
i'm saying to you is let's say you're
sitting there with your wife right now
and i make a joke a personal joke but to
you to me that's what chris is meant to
do
yeah he literally is on the show to
present that's jokes
that's his job so if you take it how you
take it he literally does that for a
living
everyone has to know him
yeah in terms of like defending her or
going to suffolk
[Music]
chris rock supposed to know she had
alopecia he doesn't
like in front of everyone that he could
have
but like
he was just acting up he was acting our
character like yo
you're just trying to prove a point
in the moment and you think after
anything like maybe a bit too much do
you i'm saying it happens bro yeah no
like maybe if you're like
you know 18 but
i'm sorry if like a grown ass man you
don't you're not in control enough of
your emotions tonight
nice it's hard
it's hard that was a big audience
yeah so then so then so then grow a pair
and leave don't you don't have to like
you don't have to put up with that
and like like imagine imagine okay if
jada was a dude okay and and or let's
say will smith did it he hooks up with a
20 year old
that is addicted to drugs that they took
in from the time he was like 15. she was
like 15. and then he sleeps with her
all right
like you don't you do you think the
world would have like
no he would be done yeah it's such a
double
standard and it's like like she's almost
i would say predatory to be honest and
entanglement she said an entanglement
that would
she give it a whole different meaning
obviously i'm gonna read super chats for